this is the sign of a club in crisis
with a leadership so unpopular the
entire executive board was warned to
stay away from today's game as Everton
crashed into their ninth consecutive
defeat their chance of sack the board
but no one from the board was here at
goodison Park they'd been warned to stay
away a security team said it was not
safe
in a statement Everton FC said the board
members received the instruction
following malicious and unacceptably
threatening correspondence received by
the club and increasing incidence of
anti-social Behavior including targeted
physical aggression at recent home
matches it has been quite an
extraordinary day here at Everson FC
with that statement coming just a few
hours before today's match against
Southampton the management say it has
been a profoundly sad event for the club
and its fans but the fans we've spoken
to say actually what they feel is anger
Everton has only won three games this
season some small groups of fans look to
Target their frustration at Players
management and Club staff as they left
the stadium after tonight's defeat
meeting a strong police presence in
response very noticeable and rightly so
I think I think
change is due shall we say there
shouldn't be situations like that where
people are fearful they're coming to a
football match because they may be
assaulted that's ridiculous I'm cold Fed
Up and that's it Everton's manager Frank
Lampard conceded there is pressure it's
difficult period there's so much passion
at this club you know for various
reasons and the right reasons everybody
here at the club wants to the best for
the club and of course over years
we've come in this direction that now
we're in relegation battle last year
relegation battle this year so I think
it's as much as I need to sign it
tonight Everton's owner Farhad mashiri
says he stands by Frank Lampard as
manager but today's security warning is
unprecedented in the club's history with
some fans saying it reflects just how
toxic things have become Catherine
libertad Sky News Liverpool